lockdown it's stressful for everyone but
you know children it's particularly
August you can't really explain it to
them or anything but you were doing a
lovely thing with meditation especially
for kids yeah we health and wellness
fitness app we brought out a couple of
years ago has meditations for adults and
a friend of ours said you want you try
these meditations for your kids and I
thought it's not gonna work you know my
kids can't sit still back on and we
started doing it and it was fantastic
and even though sort of sleep
visualizations and positive thinking and
so on and so I recorded a few children's
meditations on our app and as did talk a
whitey who directed for Ragnarok and Jo
Jo rabbit and yeah so and people are
loving it it's it's yeah yeah you know
say you say there for children
judging from Twitter I think other
people are enjoying them here's a lady
this is definitely more from mommy than
baby
this one chris hemsworth guided
meditations on center thinly-veiled for
kids you're welcome that is all
and this Sadie listen to Chris hamsters
meditation out with the kids now mommy
just needs to pop off for some alone
time
hashtag Thor hashtag for and I have to
say Chris like when you listen to this I
do get what they mean here's a little
clip of you helping the meditation
everybody
I all tucked up in bed feeling warm and
comfortable
and take a few big breaths into your
belly and each time you breathe out feel
your body goes soft and wobbly like
jelly oh thank you for that Chris thank
it's that moment of Zen oh it's
beautiful
[Music]